residents across Southern California are
on edge after a powerful earthquake
another one struck last night this after
another quake rocked the area just days
ago this one last night was a magnitude
7.1 it rolled through the Los Angeles
area it was felt throughout the state
and into Mexico and Nevada some injuries
were reported roads were closed a few
fires were started it was stronger than
that magnitude 6.4 quake on July 4th
Carter Evans is near the epicenter in
Ridgecrest California Carter good
morning good morning Jeff you know these
earthquakes had just rocked this
community and they've done a lot of
damage this is just one small example
inside the East Ridge market we're here
at Ridgecrest after the first quake and
then at 8:19 last night the shaking
started again and grew increasingly
violent everybody ok this is the first
glimpse of the damage inside a
Ridgecrest supermarket tiles fell from
the ceiling food and other items flew
off the shelves the air is really thick
dusty this is a bad one gas lines
ruptured sparking numerous fires
California officials say they're bracing
for the worst there have been a number
of injuries reported there's been a
significant increased number of EMS
calls to the 911 centers huge priorities
right now for medical support and for
firefighting and for emergency power
even in Los Angeles more than 150 miles
away strong here 821 here on the air
we're experiencing very strong shaking I
think we need to get under the desk all
right we're gonna go to break we'll be
right back Wow
the magnitude 7.1 quake came just one
day after Thursday's 6.4 jolt which at
the time was the largest earthquake to
hit California in two decades
[Music]
that quake turdy life into chaos without
warning turned out to be a foreshock but
this is what's left behind the region
was just starting to clean up like the
volunteers at the Ridgecrest library
picking up thousands of books that fell
from the stacks we're just so thankful
it was closed can you imagine those
books falling on some poor kid or some
elderly person the library was also
closed when last night's quake hit
elsewhere in Ridgecrest security video
captured the shaking and a laundromat
and inside this convenience store the
tape stops as the power cuts out we
talked to the store owner tony abdul
latif how much do you think you lost
here be honest with you from yesterday
and today I would say about a hundred
thousand no insurance no insurance for
the quake of of course you gotta have
earthquake insurance and even then it
usually doesn't cover the contents of
your home the damages to this store are
going to cost a lot of money and it the
cost of this community is going to be
much higher the good news is there are
no reports of injuries or deaths but the
aftershocks continue and seismologists
say the probability of another strong
one occurring over the next few days
is very high Jericka wow that's so scary
Carter thank you to give you an idea of
just how far away the quake was felt
here's a look at the rollercoaster at
the New York New York Hotel and Casino
on the Las Vegas Strip it was shaking
you guys can see that right there during
the quake which was about 200 miles away
also in Las Vegas the opening night of
the NBA Summer League had to be
postponed there were concerns that the
arena may have become structurally
unsound the game was sold out as anxious
fans were awaiting the debut of New
Orleans pelicans rookie Zion Williamson
can you even imagine that board up above
the court if you've ever been on one of
those and seeing that shaking it looked
like people very calmly left the arena
but still there's so much uncertainty
yeah a lot of frayed nerves in
California right now which is why it's
good idea to have a plan for everybody
no matter where you are right if
disaster strikes for the family talk
about what you're gonna do if something
happens and especially because they're
saying that it's going to continue that
there will be more aftershocks